imagine if all the Earth's oxygen
disappeared not forever just for say
five seconds would we just hold our
breath what would happen to the
atmosphere what would happen to the
environment this is what if and here's
what would happen if the world lost
oxygen for just five seconds take a nice
deep breath feel how satisfying that is
what you're breathing in is oxygen and
it takes up roughly 21% of our
atmosphere with 78% being nitrogen
although it's not the most abundant gas
in our atmosphere it is the most
important without oxygen plants animals
water and us humans wouldn't be where we
are today
five seconds may not sound like a whole
lot of time to be without oxygen most of
us can go at least thirty seconds
without taking a breath so it would
happen too fast for your body to even
notice your breathing would actually
remain normal but as for everything else
not so much in just five seconds the
earth would look completely different
without oxygen you can say goodbye to
the Hoover Dam the Pantheon dome and
anything else made of concrete
these structures would instantly
collapse oxygen acts as a special
binding agent to concrete without it
concrete is just dust speaking of
buildings any untreated metal would
instantly be fused together this is
because there's a layer of oxidation on
metals that prevents them from welding
together without that layer metals would
instantly bind to each other if you
happen to be relaxing at the beach at
the time expect a severe sunburn the
ozone layer our protection against the
sun's UV rays is made of oxygen take
away the oxygen and the earth would
become extremely dangerous there would
be nothing protecting us from the sun's
UV rays in addition to a sunburn our
inner ear would explode losing oxygen
means losing 21% of our air pressure a
change in air pressure that drastic is
equivalent to being at sea level and
dropping down 2,000 meters instantly our
ears wouldn't have enough time to adapt
having a good time yet well don't expect
it to last long without oxygen
there's no fire the combustion process
and vehicles wouldn't be able to occur
any mode of transport that isn't
electric will automatically fail planes
will fall from the sky and millions of
cars will be stopped in their tracks the
sky would be completely dark before it
hits the earth light from the Sun
bounces off multiple particles in the
air without oxygen in the atmosphere
there are less things to bounce off and
the sky will appear dark oh yeah and
while all this is happening the Earth's
crust would completely crumble that's
because Earth's crust is made up of 45%
oxygen the crust would crumble and
continue to crumble until there's
nothing left sending you and everyone on
the planet into a freefall sound like
fun probably not but luckily you can
take a deep breath of 21% oxygen knowing
this will never happen for more things
that are fun to speculate on keep
checking back with what if
[Music]
you